so it's almost the end I needed you've
already wrapped filming but how is it
sort of you know this journey been for
you knowing that soon after all the
episodes air this will be over
it feels impossible to wrap my head
around I'm grateful that we didn't have
to say goodbye completely when we
finished filming in November that we get
this opportunity well I'm alone right
now but we've had this opportunity this
week to all be together and to celebrate
the show now that it's finished and
about to Air and that we get to share it
with everyone
um
I think we'll probably be saying goodbye
for a long time
no absolutely but did you take anything
from set or is there something you wish
you had taken from set
oh what do I wish I had taken from set
all the furniture out of midge's
apartment I wish I'd taken from that
would have been a little big I'd have to
bring a U-Haul to the last day of
shooting
um I took all the coats
I don't have them yet they're sitting in
a warehouse in New Jersey somewhere but
with a box with my name on them and I'm
gonna wear them I'll be in coats for the
rest of my life Donna zakovska Originals
I like to think like you're like on a
red carpet somewhere and so it's like oh
who are you wearing it's like oh it's
just from marvelous Miss Mesa yeah it's
a down as a comsca
I love it I love it um also your husband
has uh joined this season whose idea was
that was it yours was it his was it
Amy's how did that all come about
Amy has always loved Jason and uh I I
can't honestly I can't remember there
was a role that she had kind of said she
didn't know how big a part it was gonna
be last season and it ended up doing two
episodes and then she decided to write
eight or nine episodes this season so it
just kind of felt really organic
um was it you guys have worked together
previously am I correct in that yeah
yeah I mean you worked together
previously but um how is it working
together on this it was really fun it
Jason's been helping me learn lines for
the show since the audition I think for
it and he was working on his show in
Vancouver when we started working on
this and so it just felt very full
circle and and nice I think mostly for
him to get to see what I've been doing
all day while I've not been at home for
14 hours a day for the last six years
but it was a lot of fun
awesome
um now for manage I mean this character
is just I mean it's just a wonderful
character but what has if you can put
into words like what this character has
meant to you
yeah I mean I'll probably be finding the
words for this for a long time but
maybe just someone who
looks adversity in the face and then
immediately looks at how many more doors
she can open or Windows and and and you
know how many places she can break
through to find her way around it and
I suppose Midge has inspired me to be a
little bit braver in my own life and I'm
really grateful for that
you know as I know you're
your of your career what are you most
looking forward to
it's a great question
I'm most looking forward to
getting to try on different women for
size I I have loved this experience in
ways that I never could have expected
I'm someone who gets a little wand or
Lusty and itchy and loved the
opportunity for so many years to jump
from character to character and I didn't
expect how rich The Experience would be
to get to sit with one character for so
many years and to find brand new colors
to her year after year
um but I'm looking forward to getting
back to jumping around a little bit and
getting to drop in and out of different
worlds
[Music]
all of these characters
um what is sort of like the fan like
what do you hope they take away from
this last season
I hope they feel like we landed the
plane I hope they feel like everyone's
stories wrapped up enough and still left
some to the imagination so that they can
dream about what happens to these
characters next I hope they feel good
because they've been so good to us for
so many years as you said it's one of
the kindest
gentlest loveliest fan bases I've ever
experienced and I I just hope that we've
done it justice for them
um and sort of just taking you back to
your last sort of days of filming you
know uh
how was that like you know
some people were you kind and other
people cried sort of what was the
environment going on then
it was definitely emotional
we just have loved working together so
much it shouldn't be a very rare
experience but I think unfortunately it
is we just love each other so much of
our crew has been here since the first
season and so it felt like this
collective experience and we have a big
crew it's a big show so there were
hundreds of us just kind of looking at
each other going oh my God I can't
believe it I can't believe it's the end
but the best part about that last week
was that we all got to spend it together
almost every person who had been on the
show for any significant amount of time
over the the course of the couple years
was there for that last week and so we
got to close the chapter together and
that was pretty special but yeah we were
all I mean I've I've been saying it but
Alex and I could not look each other in
the face during the last day
she surprised me she was just as bad as
I was maybe worse she was uh yeah I we
rehearsed our final scene together and I
was looking at her forehead and she was
looking at my mouth so we didn't have to
look at each other until we actually got
to shooting because we weren't gonna
make it